you got to feel kind of so at home at
these things now don't you man we really
do especially in Canada you know up here
it's amazing and being back at boots and
hearts it feels it feels like home feels
like a little homecoming here it's been
a couple years so we're so excited man
to be back and you know anytime we get
to be on the road and see our fans were
excited but there's just something about
being up here man it's awesome
when you get to play live and you have a
bunch of new hits there around like I
mean you hit if you hit a home run out
of the gate like you did with Cruz I
mean a lot of people might might be like
excited about that but they know look
what we have to do we got to follow that
we set the bar high ourselves and you've
done it again and again and again and
now most recently with with your friend
bebe what about that song meant to be
man just super thankful to be a part of
a song that that's that huge I mean that
song is blown Armand every step of the
way from when we recorded it to kind of
hurt releasing it to it blowing up on
streaming and it's on pop then it's on
country and it's it's just it's just
wild and it just it's a cool Rahman or
the power of a great song and the power
of music that's why we all got into this
thing in the first place because we love
music we've been touched by songs and
just to be a part of something that
magical every night watching it just
explode live and people really
connecting to it and making it their own
I think it's just inspiring to us you
know in the middle of recording our
fourth album and writing more songs and
trying to get other stuff cut so it's
just just a cool circle how it all it's
all inspiring and then we're just living
our dreams out it's great I know you
knew we've talked about it a few times
but you guys knew you had something
special when you wrote Cruz can you
sense you have a better sense now of or
does it get better every year you're
you're keenly aware of a special moment
or a special turn of phrase or a special
chord progression can you tell when
there's something special that you guys
have come across I think I think so I
mean I think you know songwriting we're
just trying to always better that craft
you know of ours and really better our
ears as well and be able to hear that
that's that's one of the goals so
hopefully we've gotten better over the
last few years but we're also surrounded
by a lot of amazing songwriters in
Nashville
our publishing company tree boughs music
you know we're really fortunate to just
have some of the best in town and be
able to learn and grow as well as the
rest of our writers so uh yeah hopefully
our ears are getting better and we're
able to hear you know hear the hits you
know pick a winner but I mean not just
the ones that you hear other people
pitching you and stuff but the ones when
you write something it really like when
you're like oh man I've never done that
before on the guitar or something on the
piano or something special you kind of
like the hairs rise in the back your
neck or something yeah I don't know if
it's a chord thing but I do know for
sure like when we're writing sometimes
it's just like oh this one's special and
let's not mess this one up yeah yeah
are there some I mean I know that you
guys are shooting a video I think as
this this might be breaking some
confidentiality thing but you're
shooting a video next week for the next
single can you tell me about it a little
bit uh you know it's I think the video
is gonna be just beautiful you know it's
uh we're gonna have our wives in it and
it's gonna be kind of sexy it's gonna be
kind of artsy it's gonna maybe making
music maybe making music alright the
title is talk you out of it I'll talk
you out of okay so that's one of the
songs that you released you guys did you
like Netflix did you release three songs
simple Colorado and talked you out of it
like with interlace another one in a
couple weeks what is going on the music
industry is on it's been turned upside
down they flip the switch on the old hit
factory and they just here to come we
just want to get the music out to the
fans man it's gonna be a few months till
we get the album out so we just want to
start you know giving them some new
music well that's amazing right because
people have gotten used to in this kind
of on-demand world or when you know
Netflix puts a new series out and you
can binge watch it all in one night if
you have the time now you guys are
releasing music as you've got it instead
of just you know you're given obviously
there's a thirst for it a desperate
thirst for it
why sit on it for look for too much
longer you're kind of doing a really
that's a different thing though that's a
little unorthodox right uh yeah I mean
we've taken our time with this album but
you know we we also kind of strategize
and want to make sure we put it out the
best time and the rollout plan and all
that I mean all that's part of what we
go into you know the strategic part of
releasing some some out some albums so I
think next year around February and
March we're gonna release this album and
start touring there pretty soon after
that so
so yeah we just wanted to wait for a new
year and a fresh start but also get some
get some of the ones that really excited
about here out of the gate and let the
fans go ahead and you know start jamming
what's the you guys go in with kind of
like a game plan for an album or does it
start with a song because we're talking
about a new album coming out is there is
there a game plan is there a message is
there kind of an arc you know every
every albums been different I think for
us and usually it does start with like a
song or two I think we have like a
little batch and then we just kind of
grow from there and just try to try to
be as real as we as we can be with where
we're at in our lives and you know find
the best songs write the best songs that
we can and just stack our record with
hits to be honest with these songs that
are powerful songs that move us songs
that we know that are gonna move people
whether that's out of their seat or or
that's into a certain emotion so we're
just yeah we just we just want to put
out the best songs that we can and and
and you know i think i think the
matically it they all come they all end
up working because we're all kind of in
the same place